The two most important data governance roles are
data owners and data stewards, but there are other
roles. When asked who has responsibility
for data governance in an organization,
the answer must be everyone. Much like
requiring staff to agree to a code of ethics,
or adhere to particular values, if an
organization employs data governance,
the expectation must be that all staff agree
to support the function of data governance.
What other roles have particular
importance regarding data governance?
There are a range of technology roles, such as a
database administrator, or a software developer,
both of which, for example, manage many aspects
of creating, reading, updating and deleting data.
They may have special requirements relative to
data governance, such as adherence to industry
regulations. We know, for example, that everyone
who handles health care data must follow specific
data handling rules, like what can be stored and
who can access it. Other roles include attorneys
who advise data owners and stewards about data
requirements, such as privacy or disclosure, there
are auditors who are tasked with making sure that
all of the organization's data is being handled in
accordance with policies, and there's security
professionals who identify vulnerabilities to
the data security and confidentiality, and
make sure that all data is being kept out of
reach of those individuals both inside and
outside the organization who shouldn't have
access to it. There are also those people who
capture and input data. For example, sales clerks
who handle credit cards and might have access
to customer's contact information, or telephone
support agents who are working with your customers
to resolve any questions or issues they may have.
When thinking about these roles, you
must think about the following questions.
Are each of these roles sufficiently trained?
What can be done to reduce data entry
errors and maintain high quality?
Finally, there's a critical role for management,
all levels of management must help to communicate
value and support enforcement. If
data governance is not supported,
and messaging from management isn't clear
or inconsistent, it will be less successful.